what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video this is gonna be a
quick update video but I do have some
news about one filming location that I
have reported on in previous videos I'm
giving away all seven seasons of Game of
Thrones and so far there is only two
winners so there are still plenty of
time to enter this giveaway if you want
a chance at winning a copy of one of the
Game of Thrones seasons just follow the
link that's down in the description as I
started making his videos some more news
just came out about season eights
filming schedule so I will update you on
that as well but first I want to discuss
the filming location in Northern Ireland
that was used for Riverrun I have to
thank my friend zip who lives in
Northern Ireland for sending me some
photos once again I made a video a
couple weeks ago because there was some
reports coming out from an Irish Thrones
fan account that said the Riverrun
location was very busy and operational
at the moment this led me to believe
that we may see Riverrun for the last
time in season 8 as far as I know admir
Tully was last seen at Riverrun when he
helped Jamie get inside the castle when
the blackfish refused to hand it over to
the Lannisters in the phrase but after
ed meer helped them get inside Jaime
returned to the twins where Walder Frey
held a celebration and this is when
Walder Frey told Jaime that he had ed
near put back in the cells
ever since the season 6 finale ed meer
has not been seen or heard of since then
so I was hoping we would get some sort
of closure with this character when my
Northern Ireland friend zip drove past
this filming location there was no
longer any ro activity going on the set
wasn't completely torn down yet but
there was some security guards watching
over the property both times that he
went there and took photos so I was
hoping once filming began we would see a
little bit more presence at this site
but zip sent me some photos last night
and as of right now the set is basically
abandoned there are no longer any
security guards watching over the place
and he said it appeared that they have
started to take down more of the castle
so as of right now it seems like we will
not be seeing Riverrun in season 8
filming begins this month an actor has
already started to show up in Belfast to
prepare to film but if they're already
taken down more of this set before most
of the filming begins and I don't think
it's likely that they're gonna be
filming anything here I was really
hoping Jamie Lena
would make a pit stop here while he was
on his way to Winterfell but I'm no
longer as confident that that will
happen but my friend said he would stop
here again in a few weeks and give me
another update just in case this
location becomes active again but I do
want to say just because Riverrun might
not be used doesn't necessarily mean we
won't see ed near Tully again he could
still pop up in Winterfell on his own
brands gonna notify everyone that he saw
the night King destroyed the walls so I
can only imagine Songza is gonna call
all of their banners and John's gonna do
the same Jaime Lannister could still
stop at the twins on his way north and
rally as many men as possible - so I'm
not gonna row add more Tully out just
yet and as soon as I get another update
I will let you all know as soon as
possible - now let's get on to the other
news about season 8 and I will be the
first one to say that you're probably
not gonna like what you're about to hear
but as of right now it appears that
season 8 won't begin until 2019 I know
there was already some news circulating
about this but liam Cunningham made it a
little bit more clear when he was
interviewed by TV Guide he did say each
episode in season 8 will be bigger and
longer than ever before but they're
planning on filming all the way up until
the summer which means it's not gonna be
ready to premiere in a summer if they're
still filming because they're still
gonna need to edit it and score it and
do the CGI and everything else last
season they filmed up until February but
it's looking like they're gonna be
filming several months after that but
the good news is if they are filming for
this long then that means we should see
a lot more footage especially since
there is only six episodes in the final
season and they are filming longer than
they would for a 10 episode season so I
guess you have to take the good in a bad
with this news we will have to wait a
little bit longer but hopefully this
means they will deliver a better product
so stay tuned for more details because
filming is about to begin in full force
so I'm sure there's gonna be more news
and photos leaking by the day I also
want to give a heads-up to everybody
that supports this channel on patreon I
am gonna be doing a live stream once a
week from here on out and the live
streams will be patreon exclusives so if
you support this channel on patreon you
have access to my weekly live streams I
will post a link there that way you can
come and watch live and chat with me and
I will hopefully be able to answer
everyone's questions I figured this is a
little something that I can give back to
those of you who have supported this
channel financially I really appreciate
any and every bit of help that I have
received but now it's time to announce
the next winner of the Game of Thrones
series giveaway the first-place winner
was already picked and they did contact
me and they asked for Season seven so
whoever wins today can have any season
they won except for season seven since
somebody already picked that today's
lucky winner is Harsha
congratulations just send me a private
message on youtube or you can send me an
email and tell me what season a game of
Thrones you won good luck to everybody
else that has participating in the
giveaway and I want to thank everybody
for watching the video I really do
appreciate that and for those of you on
patreon I will be streaming at 8 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time every Friday so I
hope to see you there have a great day
everyone I will see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you